c'est l'histoire d'une grande famille ou
d'une grande classe qui se retrouvent
chaque année au mois d'août
comme d'habitude on y retrouve le
professeur exigeant
durant une dizaine de jours
les cours sont à la carte 23 disciplines
une cinquantaine de professeurs et plus
de 600 élèves venus apprendre
l'excellence comme pour ce cours de
modern jazz extrêmement suivi je leur
apprend à mieux utiliser leur corps
leurs muscles à mieux respirer en
mouvement claquettes talons basket ou
encore en chaussettes il y en a pour
tout les pieds et pour tous les styles
parmi les élèves des amateurs et des
semi professionnels se côtoient mais un
juste milieu est vite trouvée on apprend
tout le temps de toute façon à guider on
aide aussi des débutants parce que bon
c'est pas semblé fans commençaient à
danse sportive et après moi je suis
débutant dans d'autres danseuses nues
quand je sais pas du tout à ce n'était
pas le festival darc reste un stage de
danse en perpétuel mouvement
au sens propre comme au figuré il
souhaite désormais s'agrandir davantage
on sent bien qu'on arrive à quelque
chose de butoir vu le nombre de
stagiaires et que pour ne pas devenir un
supermarché de la danse parce que c'est
parce que l'on veut il faut une de
structures d'accueil style chapiteau
supplémentaires et le dernier jour un
spectacle final regroupant toutes les
danses sera présentée au public